well that pretty much wraps up today's
video thank you guys so much for
watching and
i'll see you in the next video kimberly
landon clifford has died at the age of
19.
the youtube star became famous for
sharing his life as a teenage dad and
husband with his wife cameron and their
two
daughters welcome back emily today is a
very special day
exciting day and very nervous day as
today
cameron is going to be giving birth to
our lovely baby girl delilah
according to a gofundme page the father
of two suffered from a brain injury
landon's wife announced the
heartbreaking news with a photo of her
hand on his chest
as he laid in what appears to be a
hospital bed
she wrote august 13 2020 was landon's
last day being the best dad and best
husband
he could be after spending the following
six days in a coma
he passed on and donated several organs
to people in need all over the country
he died saving the lives of others
that's the type of person he was
compassionate loving thoughtful kind and
gentle
he literally just had a baby so what
about another one
like what are we gonna get another baby
huh it's just because we make such cute
babies
cameron added that this isn't how things
were supposed to go
writing he was so young and had so much
more life to live
he was an amazing husband and the best
father those girls could have
ever asked for it saddens me deeply that
they will never get to
truly know him youtube personality noted
that words cannot come close to describe
the pain i feel
landon and cameron got married in june
2019 and are parents to daughters
colette and delilah
from their videos which had titles like
teen dad's first time alone with both
babies now it's delilah and daddy time
you're so adorable mommy just left me
here
all alone with you huh and teen dad
tries labor
pain stimulations back in the older days
they didn't really
let men into the delivery room
so what decade did that start happening
did they start allowing men to be there
for the birth
uh i'm going to say 1956
1956 wrong it was actually 1970s
the family of four have been sharing
their lives to more than one million
subscribers
on youtube cameron concluded her post by
writing
all i can do now is make sure our girls
know how much he loved us
he's looking down on us from heaven and
his light will shine through the clouds
when we look up at him
may he rest peacefully